[Music]
[Music]
what is up everybody good morning happy
Thursday we are making it through this
week slowly but surely you guys we're
back again because the cod beta is back
again yep but they got the cross play
action this time so you know they even
tell you right in the beginning
once you loaded up you could play across
all three platforms in this beta
let's go join us but I'm Persian
this is Ritchie we're gonna play some
Cod today and ya watching you guys are
watching Ritchie's POV today no worries
no worries I am seeing in chat though
that some of the Xbox players has are
having issues so it is possible that the
update is not 100% available yet Darrell
says our engine is working on the
problem well that's true cuz yeah y'all
need to get on this is not fair see we
got our people that remember you
remember last time so I guess we'll run
some quick play matches a lot of game
modes are open today we can even play A
to B to gun fight together yeah so we'll
hop around through the playlist say show
this off and we were kind of just
talking about it before this dream but
we were like oh we have the advantage
now cuz we're leveled up from last
weekend yeah and it didn't reset our
stats or anything so there's gonna be
some people playing for the first time
yeah a lot of rookies you know hopefully
they're enjoying it cuz we still are for
sure it's why we're back at it again
back Eddie what's up everybody hey
thank you all for joining yes thanks for
being here
I hope for our Xbox users that it gets
fixed quickly quickly someone in the
chat saying this is my day off and I
can't play at this well you know that
the day is still early I'm sure they are
working really hard on it
although yeah on the East Coast it might
be a little later in the day we hope we
hope it's up and running soon we're not
finding out about this until now is big
game mod open or the game mode
hey crime yes it is we can play a 20 be
20 domination I think oh my goodness
[Music]
yeah okay well alright you guys know I
feel really bad
Thank You Lou tessie's so I'm sorry
about that wrong I know team Chad he's a
pride team Chad he was there oh I'm
already getting stunned over here oh oh
hello oh yeah y'all looking at my feet
god I'm being watching Richie today what
makes this cod game different from the
other Cod games well in my opinion it's
not crazy different
you know there are better adjustments
it's like a more enhanced version in
various thanks to Lee from sound general
gameplay gun gameplay they've changed up
the you know kind of perks systems the
game incorporated it with the
attachments so most of the really good
things you get are kind of tied to how
you build your gun how how you build
your class like you used to new and it's
still abhi that you just colored
definitely taking feedback from the
community so far on what they you know
prefer with the game they are changes
have been made already and for the most
parts for the better
October 25th yes that's when the game
actually comes out it's checking out
chat it's more realistic yeah you have
any mission play the objective so
nothing is actually final but I mean it
feels pretty good to meet I will say
when I was first for you I kind of felt
like is a little slow and clunky but now
that I've been playing for a little
while longer and they even though the
level cap is at 20 right now I do think
that is just a part of not everything
being accessible yet was camping out
their new HQ I gotta move we're not
playing on PC we're playing on ps4 but
if it's cross-play beta
so he's dealing in xbox one when Xbox
one in the chat remembers chat yep
good time to chat
we got a channel that chat energy Chad
was the guy we played with once and he
was goat and we miss him dearly
that was not his aim was good not mine
oh yeah I've definitely been using
claymore is way more great I haven't won
every class now people have said that
though he already
I mean claimers have always been pretty
cheap but they do have bike racks and
stuff
that'll make you take less explosive
damage that isn't that's right they have
a counterpart yeah
No I can't respond oh no my friend
I know head critters once you die he has
an HQ yeah fun watching you guys play
says Ricky wish I could play with you
guys but Xbox is stupid well hopefully
once it's up maybe were you trying to
invite some people in yeah well you guys
are here keep trying I mean we want to
see maybe and we want to see how it how
it is crawling you know across platforms
I know some people were worried about
you know it's not going to be fair if PC
is on cross play also and they're on
mouse and keyboard but we found out last
time that they are gonna separate mouse
and keyboard players from controller
players even if they are on PCs
supposedly that's right and if you don't
like cross play at all regular menu
oh I didn't know that yeah it's all this
morning
Oh HQ let's go I play everything every
team every mode like a team deathmatch
is an issue for sure yeah gonna be an
objective boy I know sprout doesn't work
that way also his barrel said I was here
waving way back in the day like Xbox
Live was the superior FPS community -
like PSN look back then playstation
Online was free yeah you know people
didn't have to you know okay to play
online with other people so I think
that's why yeah people thought it was
better competition I played a little of
both and like oh I'm here at the
headquarters
great I played a little above and it was
definitely high up on Xbox plus they had
a partnership with Activision you know
like how they have it now you have to
play first 90s for but last time you see
go through six
but yeah whenever I played on whenever I
played halo back in the day was like you
can use X BC which was like the free PC
version o to play and then you get you
or you can I have xbox live which is
where the better community ones but in
terms of cod stuff yeah everyone are
always like man it was very cool I'm not
sure how I feel about it now like which
community is actually better
I don't think over time my hands have
gotten use of the PlayStation controller
but I do think that the Xbox controller
is maybe a little bit more comfortable
I'd really like them both it's nice to
break it up there
oh the HQ why don't I go to HQ like
hopping all over the place people jump
so much children quit jumping think of
like fortnight kids jumping shoot oh I'm
gonna be really nasty right now check it
out
is it activated by default or you have
to turn in line it's activated by
default I'm sure in the lobby is away
from Max's PlayStation stays winning the
PlayStation nation up in here yeah you
know a PlayStation C's winning and other
aspects than maybe like there is grounds
so you talk about skill level of
community as PlayStation has been
killing it they've been having all the
early access stuff so it's not really
winning no you dealing with campers
round corners around the corners with my
with my aim up combustion so sooo bad
Cod is not on switch I mean they just
announced mobile you guys remember when
like all most of the cod games made it
to the Wii and they're kind of butchered
but it was kind of fun I'm down let's go
for a generation Cod honestly yeah it's
not out of the realm of possibility you
like this matte Persia do I know what do
you like this map ah I do and I don't at
the same time me too I wanted to wanted
sometimes I do really
but then sometimes I get just stuck in
the spawn yeah I got body playing
realism mode on this map specifically I
got destroyed yeah what's that like
let's go disable HQ friends Carson says
the PS 5 is gonna continue the greatness
you know what I'm ready for
I'm reminded me about PS 5 actually
alright chat let's be real you remember
way back in the day you're like sitting
around James you know joking and I'd
yeah wondering like 100 years
yeah like po6 we're very close to it we
are it's climbing I didn't think we'd
make it I don't know why I just ever I
had those same talks no growing up like
that 20 PS 9 commercial gotta kill
though guys how about I get a cab let's
go guys
Danny go says I need a camp a little bit
yeah you're right but it's not my style
I just can plus I don't think it works
for chat so well but I got you I'll try
it out I think I just need to calm down
a little that's all you know what this
is the first game yeah I'm already
sweating I'm hype
[Music]
what is that sound
Oh people worship know says it's all
coming together and Lazarus says I'm
ready for the Xbox oh man I know they
mixed us up with that name yeah I was
like literally in here China will never
know man they're out of the console game
you'll never see that we get some recon
you later CJ I told you chat with busy
man
we're warming up you know we are do do
right now all waiting stuck back here
that's why I'm calming down doing a
little recon inside the app though what
the oh yes we are playing on ps4 pros
right now Angelo there's apparently been
some problems with Xbox trying to get on
nothing yeah keep us updated chat this
thing yeah let us know Xbox users you
want to play with y'all yeah you know
not my best performance same I don't
know how I always get so many assists in
this game I just have you most of the
dirty work and someone else takes the
kill spike as I was rocking a silencer
Oh Andrea
don't run watch the corners listen to
the footsteps team up a little I'm just
saying I hear you
maybe I gotta calm down I'm just so
excited oh if you want we can tailor the
playlist to just play 20 V 20 oh yeah oh
my goodness 20 very some 20 v20 Dom or
headquarters
[Music]
whatever a little bit of all of them
let's just do both the I will leave both
the 20 would be the 20 player I think
it's 10 bees like 10 on 10 cool ground
war I think might be coming out later
this weekend every day they update with
different stuff actually they did they
did that last weekend to brownies yeah I
know man we're trying to I was too hype
in that first match excuse me for that
one how do you get the beta for the PC
is it Blizzard net I think they were
like hosting it I do not know but if you
go to the the website they call the duty
website they have all the info on how to
get the stuff and they have a big like
blog posts up to that kind of explains
all the modes and everything the website
this year has been very helpful for all
the beta information I've gone back to
it like a bunch at the moment
pre-ordering the game is how yeah well
now this weekend though you don't need
for your pre-order it's open this
weekend or is it next weekend for Xbox
players if you didn't pre-order it's not
available but tomorrow it'll be open for
everyone Xbox Live Gold I'm pretty sure
that's what it was weird it was just
like for a day what are we playing oh
thank you again alright I'm gonna try to
take chats in life you know I got you
know I'd love to run like this I just
love that camo that is it's very has
alone Revis is yes so even if I'm trying
to be sneaky boy we'll see
Oh No
all my friends are getting killed around
me there's one anybody playing on xbox
very hero but they were having some
issues on the Xbox side right now but it
cleared up you know sometimes when that
happens like there's air they'll make it
up in another way which is always fun
they might give you an extra day yeah
you know cuz this is this is if I run
xbox right now except hey am i sitting
on the HQ this is great oh man I am I
stuck in this window time to post up
close the door don't kick my door open
okay I wish I had one of those uh those
fortified those walls but right now I
have a recon drone instead
no they're approaching you know there's
split screen not sure if they'll have
something we got the HQ but now we're
surrounded they are but we're defending
it we got it on lock
they definitely I'm watching the back
Alois Oh any tool
please open the door while aiming down
sights fine
is that how you like creep it open I'll
be there I know last time we were trying
to figure yeah
let me test that out on a regular ass
near safety or there's not a million
people come on trying to find a regular
ass door new HQ okay forget the regular
ass door how's everyone doing on check
any word about Xbox yet they're
everywhere oh there it is crime okay
there it is I'm creating and creeping
yeah oh that's so dope I'm finally
getting this down I like doing this
alright let's actually let's to close
dumb I kind of like I'm running around
forever
I know there's people there's ten whole
other people somewhere on this man I
think we've got this HQ I like died the
same second week at the HQ so it was
like the score on the bottom left there
we got this had my phone I would check
double check all these smart creatures
open now so pop on try to download
hopefully the Xbox side of things gets
cleared out a little bit in Reno so they
added 20
there we go trash rightfully so I'm
doing Dookie right now so am I having
fun with y'all though thank you all for
joining even though you know what we're
winning yeah Oh No yes okay
I have ghosts I don't care as much about
that you lazy oh yeah rats Tony says and
I was like I'm the next that's scary I
spawned in the middle of the street like
in crossfire I hate this area it's so
open
I need a snack yeah that's right to get
over there I'm going around though I'm
not gonna rush Oh doing it for Chad nope
I'm still it's still too open here
I hate those things the personal reader
yeah that's why I haven't permanently oh
so much shooting it down with me team
player oh yeah I just heard the Rockets
like another one
oh it's been handled excellent boys I
like to play support and I always keep a
rocket on me keep that whole oh I see
you Burgess I you know the dark areas in
this game if you're running from the
outside or like so realistically extra
dark don't okay bye they never gave
after church Levin how come I can't play
if I frequented like months ago if
you're talking about Xbox apparently
there's some issues going on right now
man yeah we yeah chad has been letting
us know all morning it's very
unfortunate but hopefully they'll make
it up with like another day or something
right now Xbox can't get on the servers
whoa-oh-oh to our right you know I kind
of feel like I have a hard time hearing
which direction bullets are coming from
sometimes but it's not
Oh
I always get this level right in this
map yeah this maps there is a sniper
class that I used once it's pretty good
but it's nicer I don't know a little
under use than this beta so far what
about you well I mean you just got
sniped this probably not there's just
too many open lines of sight in this map
I like to run around but now I'm scared
I'm like snipe me
Lazarus says that's why you use
awareness I love that I'm gonna use that
I have a class with it somewhere yeah
that would help oh you know what I'm
confusing it with high alert which I
love oh the one that tells you like like
you're being aimed at yeah yeah I'm to
be a narc no 32v 32 yet I believe that's
the final weekend of the biggest amount
this weekend like maybe next weekend is
I think what's going on I gotta get my
facts straight
oh I remember when I first opened this
last weekend we were like yeah we gotta
get your feet up
no no they Swami in the same exact spot
I just got signs in Oh running zigzag
patterns Lewis this Cod does have cross
play but currently Xbox players are
unable to get on where I was gonna say
we're looking into it but we're not we
can't at the moment
that's just what chad is saying we're so
sorry Chad Activision should be looking
into it I think they are though they
have to be they have to be a crime
earlier was like just tweet at them
they're getting flooded all right why
don't I play those you guys kill okay
can you tell where the gunshots
oh good lord
kinda nurse to damage so much the skies
are hot right now there we go got some
help my yeah I'm seeing like Oh shine or
miss game modes like ground war and
stuff with a bunch of people it's just
like I've already feel like there's
someone everywhere now imagine how we're
gonna feel yeah thank you house thank
you dilapidated now I can't believe oh
my god I've been spotted
okay oh I'm gonna take it easy but I'm
gonna try to play the objective a little
more here we are getting trapped back
here I do not like this corner Oh No
the bezel is cool though it is every
when I run out there but our airspace is
not clear where is air traffic control
when you need them it's removed of
course there's a god here
crashed into the ferris wheel and HQ is
not that far from our old spot and the
ferris wheel is untouched okay how we
doing in Chad Chad
want to be there for y'all Mike says I'm
glad it doesn't look like a kids game
more realistic the better you know what
that's probably one of the biggest
upgrades it just feels like I don't know
I call Goonies always had mature tones
obviously about ah this feels like it
feels even more so killed me and they
ran into a clear day I keep looking like
a tower mini-map and seeing all of us in
the tiniest little Corey White's has
finally got it going
this is rough oh my goodness there are I
don't have nearly enough Rockets okay
all right I know they are let's go
trying to sneak over here oh I see the
other guy camping over there he's so far
though I don't want to contest it convex
comet ghosts was good though you guys
played ghosts very much I played a
little I fell off no try to save our
game go test it out y'all
join us fight me oh baby yeah have a
good chance to kill me that spawn was
him
we took the hell man so here
that was crazy jump in xbox level things
out show what's up
I know right like PlayStation looks like
I spawned there killed one guy and he
was there tearing he killed me are you I
just got bopped in the billikin oh
that's nasty look at that kill that was
the worst case Mac thank you for joining
us we need some warm-up rounds and gun
fight that's what we need it down okay
in it yeah because you know let's take
it Before we jump into the whole ocean
full of sharks need to swim with the
little each first swim with the minnows
in the little pond
Robert absolutely terrible game oof yeah
keep watching but uh sorry feel that
what did it feel that my Katie was so
terrible I don't I don't disagree
Paul can you invite people from ps4 to
Xbox yes yeah the first triangle you can
see the oh it's my screen there you go
you can pick from your Activision
friends or your local PlayStation
friends stack here we go a little - V -
yeah oh this is a new map I don't think
Oh is in the Alpha did you play the
Alpha I did say the Alpha but I don't
remember this one oh it was there
try running and mailing Bob Jones I've
tried that you got a m-- [ __ ] who got
one go yeah he's up top you kind of
stayed on their side you have a nasty
rocket nope I was gonna be dirty about
it I'm gonna yeah really ugly this if
they show this kr Molly I guess I got
scared that was clean
I got scared shot and jumped and then
shot him again Lazarus this is the best
Call of Duty game man it's so fun so far
I'm gonna need a little more time with
it but it's a contender oh my god I'll
just spray him we needed to take some
players out of the area so that we can
get our lives together
that was your kill well we had it like
at the same time almost oh man a sniper
oh I'm gonna get sniped Oh what oh I
almost got him no yes oh yeah he is
right at those stairs
dad this Persia it's much more
manageable big boss of the river how
does this game feel so far
at first Persia said maybe a little
clunky I think you're getting used to it
though yeah it's been great for me
personally you ant were you I saw him
right here oh no I did it Oh Adam oh
yeah I tried to snipe him but you know I
need the respect that I'm just not that
great of a sniper
Lazarus I'm going to be playing this
non-stop here and we can't get enough
all right it's just the beta Jordan I
feel like in the beginning the reasons
why I didn't like this game we're just
thanks for this done yeah oh my god you
wiped them out very good you and over to
the back actually I will say you have to
just level up a bit because when you
don't have anything and walking you're
just using basic classes it can be a
little annoying but once you level up it
will get better there are a lot of nice
guns a lot of options oh yeah that was
sloppy but I got him like in the ankle
hopefully the campaign is good oh my god
I'm hoping for that I don't think I
can't I don't see how it can't be good
sight aim like mount the walls you can
do that in this game yeah I'll show you
I think we're losing my feet yeah for
sure
it's very useful you only like oh that
was the whole game day I feel good to
win oh that one yeah it was like you
know what we kind of jumped into the
deep end here Scott let's take a step
back hydrate you know I'm getting real
sweaty need that water and everyone's
also like level 4 level 10 yeah but it
matters less than this mode because
everyone starts with the same guns every
round that's true they're picked for you
we're playing with all PlayStation users
yes see this map I remember from the
monkey killer says you want a real
gameplay battlefield that's true
I got that vibe to like inspired by
battlefield get this little screen out
of here what did I do
god speed burger let's do this Oh
single shot no oh right in the head
first blood Oh guys I'll show you how to
hug the why I'm under you oh maybe
that's you yes oh no that's him where
are you son our base is left side oh so
so so casual I wasn't sure I was going
to a Chris I thought he's gonna run
lazar says side aim is really useful yep
it's true here's how it looks
that's very cool oh no I'm told oh you
saved my life
I got you
[Music]
Oh big doses on the PC side of things
oh really might be really hot right now
yeah that shoe a lot of beautiful but
still no excuse Activision let's go
we're trying to cross play with
everybody I'm playing like I did I think
I got me my least I got my fill in the
kill feed to good stuff yeah you were
sit around it's no fair I took out your
homie you saw it right before your very
eyes oh man I forgot I can't just chuck
out the grenade
that's smart well I'm scared
oh yeah the guys on me
I think shoot I'm gonna hit him with
this AK knife you can execute people
have you done that yet he's either above
me or was that you who this guy yeah
let's get the flag yes you got him I
wanted to hit kill him at the attack
knife crime look around the corners yes
I can't in this mode man I can't eat you
all that was dope I can't be chillin
this modem and I'm running around with
goofy ass yeah you can totally reload
while aiming like 80s thing to make a
little grenade
goodness oh you saved my life again I
was being chased by that guy can we have
another match
other than two all right but we'll take
it back we got quite a few game modes to
play actually yeah
but thank you for joining us you played
cyberattack like all day last time so
yeah I was reloading like a rookies oh
look at that helpless
right in the shoulder I'm so shame the
damn hand good I'm just gonna find
something to blame right he did he did
I'm scared he's behind his wall at spawn
website oh very well wrong wall I guess
our side on the left you got him
cleaning up after my stupid master thank
you he took off when I saw him on the
other side he was like no I'm not
getting sucker right here Michael all
this game looks so good get on if you're
a if you uh have a ps4 it's open to
everybody now maybe I should stop
talking and
wait a little the solution asks yo guys
is there a war game mode and he needs to
know what there is currently bigger
modes 20 V 20 but you got to play
headquarters or team deathmatch so yeah
next weekend though 32b 30 a Christmas
cyanide baby's like that my goodness
dang yeah I feel like it was like
underpowered in this video so far ok
gotta breathe gotta breathe
chasing this guy money killer OG cod not
making a comeback people just I don't
know I don't know I think this one this
one's bringing me back I think monkey
killer oh gee I'm gonna try this but if
this is your game your game I miss every
shot on the slide over no no that's the
look though oh this is it this is maybe
not for them well we can come back it's
gotta stop fooling around
look at this guy laying down in the bag
oh man you so lucky I don't ever a flash
lights out alright be on the lookout one
guy left chat should I be a little more
campy or should I just find this fool
there is I thought you were him oh no
look see and I was like oh dang oh those
nice nice
okay Lazarus my favorite gun and call of
duty modern warfare is the ak-47 you
know what I think that's currently my
favorite I just tears through people
just like it should but this in this
mode it's randomized I'd mail surrounded
in the middle oh thank you Connor
you guys are doing says you put up a
good fight
oh my goodness I tried to get well we
won one we lost one that was so close
it was I should have got him I should
have killed them I'll take some s in the
chat for that one
give us your abs please all right did we
warm up enough yeah get back to it see
what's good all right no isacs this xbox
still isn't working uh
okay we'll do some regular not 20 player
modes first we had to do I work our way
up you know we do I'm just reading chat
I feel I feel bad for all these Xbox
users it's like it was working for a
little ranking no keep us updated
because at first for a little bit it was
working someone was in here and they
left I don't even see them in chat
anymore cuz they're probably playing but
it stopped working it looks like so that
probably means the patch is actively
rolling out right now so it's not gonna
be everyone at once but it will roll out
to all owe money killer og why do you
all like this game so much man it's just
something I played for so long you know
I'm a card fan that's all money killer
what games do you like playing man
[Music]
appreciate the updates but man it's no
good here we go team deathmatch enemy of
coming weapons hiding I'm sorry in
advance sorry
hey this guy's not even playing let's go
friend you know how many people in chat
you want to play you should be playing I
know oh there you guys alright taking it
for granted
yeah that's okay he already moved but
I was not a person that was just
inanimate objects
close these doors hmm look at the
sidewalk down maybe a little too much
I'm not I haven't killed anybody here's
what it looks like to hug the wall guys
very useful oops
all right I'm not being pushy just so we
can sew so I'm not getting rushed to
killed but I'm like
oh we switch spawns no wonder I was like
what are they oh my claim work out
something nice gotta love them claymores
do know how did I live okay check this
out I'm gonna do a dope-ass why yeah you
miss me with that cruise there's so many
buildings yeah I've been killed in a
building though with a missile check
this out oh he wasn't in there
oh I deserve that I'm just hiding out in
here I'm so scared
Oh No
I am dreaming big with my killstreak
layout right now with my first one being
8 kills oh goodness
watch out oh it happened people who
don't have the wall huggers I kind of
don't like I'm still like I barely use
it like there we go no no no whoa where
is it there it is
got to keep us off the radar folks thank
you how am I even doing right there in
the middle I'm contributing thank you
Impreza uh I am seven
I don't know it does it's weird
domination all right time to be a narc
[Music]
narc Patrol how can it be a narc when no
one's around
oh they're all in the know ten points
show yourself narc
ten points here's a fun tip that I sort
of hooked up later the very top of the
screen where my compass is the enemy is
shooting you'll see those red dots
that's kind of the direction they're in
Kingslayer
oh yeah oh you can't breath yes I can't
even like call it out he's just like on
top of this box in the middle of red box
next to be spawn I'm trying to be a
little more campy myself it's uh for
cat's sake
damping's no fun what's up chat
it's my stress Oh cuz she says I'm on
xbox there are you able to get on man do
it some prosper where can i scoop a code
for xbox I think I really wish I could
confirm I think today you had to have
pre-order but tomorrow for Xbox it'll be
open for everyone but don't quote me on
that I want to get my facts straight
check it out yeah definitely check out
their website yes because they have all
the details and Activision I think also
has a blog that has a bunch of detective
right there on the front page very
helpful if you just go to I just that
was you thank you I love claymores oh
wait is that a rocket
and he got blown up nasty you guys
playing on PC Lamar guys I just did the
most extra thing ever
what's that I like popped in and then I
drop shotted as I land okay that was so
extra this guy definitely it was like
one shot I would have hated to be killed
that way that was the most try right
thing I've ever done
Lamar we are playing on ps4 is the both
of us oh man I suck how am i doing again
oh I'm at the bottom time to pick it up
friends I'm going ham now we are where
we're winning there's a lot of places to
jump in hide inside oh yeah
I let that guy up and he did not die it
was so sad Oh someone's right above me
scary well they're all up in this one
there's a sniper up here it's been
bugging me oh man I get like two or
three hit markers but he's just too far
for me to actually finish it off so I'm
just going into the building Oh a wall
please don't be a claymore here someone
was here now they're gone okay back to
it I hate this I hate this area right
here I always get picked off there's
someone there already
who oh he got me
jumped jumpers jump shots
y'all nasties down the ground whatever
do you I'm gonna be an army okay that
was just I need to get bang from that
was trapping us the Travis let's check
anywhere
I got one that was what's your favorite
gun so far person do you have one it's
still the imports honest m4 is good very
good a case my favorite and then the m4
is like second but I said that last week
he goes my Claymore that oh nice look at
that bottom of the it's okay cuz I'm on
the top so we like really booking
bookshelf in Shh
ritzy and man they are bad oh yeah look
at that Claymore we got superior
placement Jake that level cap has not
been raised from 20 not yet you still
went positive though 85 I went 20 and 10
that clean 2.0 ratio yeah I contributed
a little bit there maybe we should
switch it European now all the pressures
on you alright we're surfers y'all can
dump on me
although Chet's Jets doing great you
guys are great thank you all for joining
us yeah it's Thursday we're one more day
away from Friday you guys yes these this
is my plan this weekend what about you
are you gonna play a little more and see
what they drop yes I am yes I'm going to
be the masochist I know that I am and
playground war when they drop
we have died alive after for work we
must all right maybe I'll just learn how
to camp that world isn't this game gonna
be cross-platform yes that's why we are
screaming look you can see a couple of
people in our lobby on PC right now oh I
saw it for a second was a little mouse
icon look right here guys
oh wow we're about to get smoked now we
got this alright we got this hopefully
and we're in the caves we got this plus
you guys if you don't like cross play
and you like Call of Duty you can turn
it off I learned this more I confirmed
it this morning there's just a regular
option that says disable cross play
umm-hmm the level cap has not been
raised from 28 I like this map but I
don't like the actual cave I'm hanging
out yeah there's a love-hate
relationship with the caves for me seems
like it's loving so far I just saw
somebody scared yeah I'm hearing
footsteps got one never feels pain I
just killed them I'm gonna disagree
what am I going chat how we doing are
you guys are you guys into this beta yet
anyone expose me we lost some people
saying I play now yeah I think well
we're actually getting matched with PC
people now so that must mean things are
starting to work or they're starting to
roll out as one maybe a slow start but
y'all I'm surrounded where is everybody
I've seen two people outside okay that's
what I deserve Kevin is the area 51 raid
still ago guys I feel all about that
isn't that coming up yeah tomorrow
tomorrow I saw that the I don't know the
government was like please don't rage
look they're like for real guys don't
you're like you will get
and then you're gonna want to blame us
to a government facility Red Hulk I am a
potato I'm very sorry I wish I could
like give this to you take over for a
second I love it but I have my good
games and bad games just Ben you got him
I did nice I did I was struggling huh
what do you guys think should I be a
little more campy like this the whole
game wait did you die at the same time
yeah I love when that happens
oh oh wow I got ten points for the trade
really worried you now I feel like
that's happened uh like that's happened
twice to me where just a knockdown and I
never got points that must be new that's
not the first time I've traded but
that's the first time I got points for
it you may never notice
I don't I got all my gear on yeah did
you play much of night vision mode last
weekend I've played like a few games
actually I played like five
but it's pretty cool it's pretty cool I
liked that one people are camping just
80s you can see where the laser is yeah
you narc on yourself when they be on
sites I don't like that but you know I
learned to adjust
I finally got someone guys yeah yes this
game this match has been rough for me oh
my god mute my life I got my running
shoes on I'm just running around this
whole map
Jori Jori yes you can lean in this game
I'll show you right now if you right
there mount like that
you only show a very small like you boot
your head just pops out like that you
don't show much of yourself it's very
helpful if you have the patience to do
it and I never do
I'm sorry but it's new it's new in this
game oh I got my recon I'm going to narc
on people here this is the best place to
narc on people watch yeah I need I need
the narc the narcan help mark cam said
that they can show dark cam narcan I
can't detect that guy him either
oh they must have the purse they do I'm
getting anti-north over here a
high-level organization right now
they're like the shadaloo you know what
does the CC forgot we're playing with PC
people against smoking I go for a diet
that's good
Deezy Deezy Guapo does the gameplay feel
smooth overall yes compare yeah you know
what we should talk about because it's
cross play and I'm not getting any lag
spikes or any issues
nabis it doesn't make me a better dough
Jason I want to play can't find a link
though I think if you're on Xbox I think
you had to have pre-ordered just for
today tomorrow it should be open this
weekend is like the official opened all
let me know what you guys want to see
and maybe another gun here I'm getting
my ass handed me I think we can afford
to switch it up here but you know we
have a few classes here if you loadouts
let me know what you guys want to see
are you serious
now as nonsense just don't ask me to
snipe please for your sake it won't the
won't even be cool
I'm running from that a certain amount
of hitmarkers it's like that
maybe I switch it up okay I was really
good someone will flank that guy m13 is
very good in this game see you spawn
they are my way over there
I think they pushed outside good I'll
flank them I'm inside the cave right now
okay good yeah they're definitely
outside here we go
did you guys set up controllers only yes
we are currently just playing on
controllers were clan controllers but we
didn't set it up to where we only get
matched up against controller people we
have a couple of PC mouse and keyboard
players in our lobby yeah a lot of them
are actually on the other team
unfortunately get away from me oh good
news I'm probably oh gosh everything is
going to arc guys oh no it's got my name
on it
that's the worst place to hide it's got
no Persia how you doing over there I'm
not doing so hot I have 14 kills but I
feel like I've died a lot okay
definitely have I'm feeling particularly
stinky in this round you have a UAV up
what's going on
nope but confirmed PC cross-play at
least is live and we're getting sub
poked actually look we can catch up I've
actually been spending a lot of time
just
I feel like I'm always on the opposite
side but I also have ghosts on so I'm
not trying to run like directly next to
other people okay I think I just need to
calm the F down I'm running around
looking for people is it rechargeable
Daniel says greetings from Poland dude I
just watch the apex Invitational that
was in Poland this was it last weekend
was that important that's so cool yeah
it's really not easy I really really
enjoyed it so hello from Poland
thank you for joining us
even though look at this look at this Oh
baby I went positive somehow I felt like
I died more than I got kills but somehow
I didn't well I'm just gonna blame the
PC players I'm just kidding it's not
obviously they're here and they are
that's our options lights oh my god
Jason Harris says TV to mode thumbs up I
really like that mode too actually
oh yeah you reminded me I need to stop
dreaming so big with these killstreak oh
yeah they unlocked us oh you got all the
clear right now I got a humble UAV and
then I went kind of crazy at the end
yeah right eight kills although I did
get this in a realism match the other
day
Wow in a realism at you know ease yeah
support hello hello
but does the guns film we're having them
previous cuts I think so I the moments I
noticed it more is like when I'm
switching weapons or when I mean ATS
seeing with the bigger guns
I can definitely like I don't know it
just seems there is a service a better
way to explain it there is a / to make
you switch it up faster so I think you
might be right you know right but also I
think the sound design really like
doesn't mess with you but it makes you
feel like the guns are heavier they let
that hit harder like check this out
actually that kind is kind of light
fight
you use the a K and you feel like it's a
heavy gun and it feels cool Oh check
this out learn this today chat thanks to
crime that was like excuse me check this
out if you aim down sights and then hold
the button you can peek just a little
bit thank you to crime for showing me
how to do that yeah we were trying to
figure it out last week Jason asks more
recoil most guns I've found pretty
balance not recoil but I've had a
handful of guns that just flare up which
ones do you think have most recoil so
far Thursday I think you were dealing
with this the other day yeah um I kind
of felt like beyke was real bouncy
mm-hmm but the interesting thing is some
of the perks they have things that
either specifically control recoil or
vertical recoil they do you can adjust
that sort of first like if you can if
you notice what type of recoil it has
optimal whatever it is you need to use
because I feel like oh oh are you in are
you in a gold shop
so I'm exposed yeah I think I had one
with a silencer the old oh you miss me
no no this guy can't be in a corner man
no way you know why do people like
playing like that it's a style okay it's
never gonna go away
got someone he was reloading fortunately
you know oh god I looked that guy up and
he didn't die okay thank goodness first
don't you know PC collars are extra buff
just kidding dad dad um how we doing in
oh sorry it's hard to do both but thank
you guys all for joining ha ha
nuts oh we live now bro yes get on if
ps4 it's ready to go xbox I believe you
had to have pre-ordered the game to play
the beta today tomorrow should be open
for all Xbox users such a weird
staggered release of the beta but I mean
if you have access get on it's so fun
getting my ass
who will sprint soms a little fast yes
there are two modes to sprint now you
can sprint like this and if you double
tap DoubleTap the stigmata and as a perk
text in the double time running speed
yeah thank you guys all for joining us
oh how can I add my playstation friends
you have to do it through the activism
profile instead of the actual like Xbox
or PSN network yeah we can show you in
between the master there is a use press
triangle and there's a separate list for
friends and friends
we like 1,000,000% have this area locked
down as long as no one runs too far into
their spawn ization that's our VTOL
warship that's it yeah someone is here
what the he was up there and he didn't
see me thank goodness and people what
class you guys want to see you use what
gun let's hear it rockets only struggle
matter yeah
oh that's one of their munitions those
blow up I never shot an enemies movie
Fox I haven't but in the description it
says shoot it if you dare or something
like that oh so it makes sense no bueno
although yeah that was pretty good
alright time to go into narco yeah give
me a vision yes
narc alert narc alert running away from
me there's one got one got another and
his home
Oh
like I got someone my Claymore way on
the other side of the map as I died back
same love that my club might feel less
bad about dying that yeah but when you
forget about it play more yeah that's
the best wow this guy straight up put
down his little shields oh man yeah I'm
being an awful narc there we go got
another okay we had some uh nineteen
solely carrying I'm flash oh yeah that's
another thing perfect you can reload
while aiming down sights yeah actually
the first time I found that out was when
I saw in someone's kill cam like they
killed me Amy down sights then they
reloaded while aiming down sights then I
get around the corner and it killed me I
was like yeah I learned that the hard
way when I was trying to shoot somebody
and I was like why isn't it firing turns
out I
yeah I only need five times because I
felt like I was running around
systematic up here he was the one taking
all the kills wasn't leaving any for us
meanwhile I don't know why I'm allowed
ice cream with such Bob Joe we did last
time we switch it up for last few sure
okay here's the screen you guys if
you're adding your your other friends
just press triangle or forget what it is
on Xbox but here's a separate menu to
add your PlayStation friends in my case
or your Activision friends you need an
Activision account I think to even play
this game so I find him here what do you
want to play little team deathmatch I
suppose now you guys are as forced to
watch my yay watch me watch me go ham in
this mode
I know it's it happens every time it
does okay so you have to plug this into
your controller and pretty here okie
dokie that aren't twenty person modes
are in the cave got to take this gamble
some time I'm just kidding in fact I
just died Taji fun thank you guys oh if
you're headed now thank you for joining
oh yeah
kolima undermine yes earlier how we at
our our cross console friends yeah
you're welcome for sure they make it
really easy fortunately all you gotta do
is press triangle technology but no you
gotta love it
plus I love Infinity Ward's UI they
always slowly but surely it's making our
way I didn't notice this Lobby did you
notice that there were articles
no pressing uh-oh
Oh No I thought there was a lot of
people over here very quiet around me no
well that's a good question
Patrick asks how does chat work when
you're partying up a cross platform
haven't seen it in action but I assume
it's I assume it's seamless like I don't
have any friends so no same way all my
friends Levite except your recent thanks
man yeah let's go friends I'm I'm really
glad you guys don't have my stream i
think if i put this controller down I'd
be doing better Blue Devil hey what's up
man
homie
[Music]
I don't want to be stuck in on this side
what the heck might happen my loadout
just change by itself to a loadout that
was not mine that was so weird I had a
pistol randomly that was crazy
well there Joe says spring
okay with others remember there are two
types of plant now and like always
depending on what gun you're rocking it
could be way down the block is hot I'm
just come on dangles then go Ben body
listen doesn't like you I'm doing
particularly bad I think cuz the
pressure is off cuz now I'm not on
stream so I'm sorry when you see my
having fun for sure every you know he's
just a bad omen bird calling you out
brother where is it I'm in the eastern
sea's
there's like a battle at sea okay that's
good in the cave running towards a I'm
running through the Seas yeah you a
these notorious wasn't this supposed to
be the 64 play video that maybe next
okay yeah I think it's um either later
this weekend or next weekend yeah I know
I'm scared
there's a Dingles near me I can sense it
I shot on a milling tell you guys I knew
it I knew it
thank you diary dangles I said I was
like dangles is near me no way come on
dude Lazarus yes the block is hot yes
Bob Jones dangles is my new rival this
guy will not let up if only we had Chad
I know rich Chad narc mode
scarily oh the cake is crazy
is it all the enemies are in the kick oh
they shot my ignore cam no it's bad in
there hey there's chicken abelian
there's no one out here no oh no I got
one yes sometimes I feel like I think to
harden there near the a entrance of the
cave be careful dangles you know what we
got to do haha
Dingles I've spawned and shot you in the
back nice clearly the revenge that I
deserve even Activision was like
no it's not me I can't wait until dead
silence is unpossible
fox mulder in the chat really grinding
my gears get Dingles I'm in Spain I'm
just getting dangled ah I got killed by
a dog I hear all these gun shots of you
and seen us
we won somehow yeah yeah oh think it's
because of dope thanks dope for the Gary
for the hardcore hey I know you must
have had that name for a long I'm
thinking it says Activision game cuz you
can it can be something else
I should have PSN idea to use your
activision yeah look it dangles at 25
kills and like 18 of those were me I
swear everybody yes Cory Activision
bared my soul and sent us to another
lobbies they were like you know what if
we've died a certain amount of times to
a single player we'll just save you and
get you out of it yep
see you later blue devil have a great
day at work
you're almost to the weekend man yes yes
all three platforms fro Zach including
PC our lobby right now is obvious
actually oh yes we're but we did have a
couple of PC players in our previous
Lobby so it was cool so you purchase you
press Start and then go to like an
account there's we can disable cross
play you know if you want to keep it ps4
peer nah bring on the competition
Christopher Daniels isn't having it bro
yeah angles in this Lobby am I about to
be shook hold up hold up no he says you
know place
jump on me at will if you pre-order the
Xbox yes you can play some cod now it is
not under any pre-order restrictions but
tomorrow why people playable music law
should be open for all know I knew that
guys I want to get to the other side
though this sites not not as fun playing
as long as dangles isn't here
he's my dinkleberg
I'm on their spine I feel like there's
only a few people in those lobby at the
moment oh yeah oh man the assist I hear
a gunshot
he had ly more than
I love closing doors I kind of wish it
wasn't like hold down the button and
charge up yourself to close the door I
was just like a peg for you sure enough
to press X
yes brother Chris if your ps4 it's open
right now just go just download it do it
do it like is that fun standing on this
one back on all day like that yes the
anti-flash perk I saw gay around here
but so many people over here y'all
brokers
where's I got him no I go there no no
you're not doing this to me I'm looking
for a fire just like there's nowhere to
go
meanwhile like mm-hmm oh no anyone know
why I'm trying to add my friend on ps4
and I don't know how these guys are
letting me still get you killed off but
I will take it I'll take them all
Bob Jones says Persia has not recovered
from the Daniels incident nope gnarrk
cam inbound I kind of missed the
munitions box over the NARC cam yeah it
also goes away whoo yep we're doing it
narcan narcan we I see they would I read
that good yes okay it goes away kind of
Narconon fools Fox Mulder s now playing
Drake I heard that guy Oh as soon as I
asked where is everyone I got man I
can't wait until dead silence is in this
game and to the guy behind you get out
of here to run into my clean mouth foes
Grim Reaper hello Grim Reaper in the
chat anymore
mm-hmm the enemy has absolutely
everything gets a cover looks like
mighty me
all right next that guy went up there to
camp again DD someone did it is a
popular spot nice yeah I had your back I
was like we're gonna get this guy the
patient station guys it's something I
will never have Red Hulk try camping
I know this miles come on I'm getting
spanked I'm going over there um you know
a bit of the same you know what it's
four against six right now well all this
sewing is his face clean like that
that's crazy I got 18 kills but I have
yet to reach a kill streak okay I'm just
kind of like mmhmm I'm still just
getting my ass handed to me trying not
to get stuck in a crowd I'm having fun
with the Chad thank you guys all for
joining yeah we've been playing a lot of
cars lately they're dropping so much
stuff so thank you oh my goodness
no they're on the train tracks oh no I'm
here well no yeah there ain't I got one
yes no I tried to run out and he
actually body-block
first on a radar yeah baby it says I
love no mini-map oh you got to play that
my friend cuz they and the regular modes
they added mini-map back yes a lot of
people didn't like the absence of
mini-map play realism mode once it comes
out nothing no bud
don't hit markers it's black kamikaze
says no mini-map belongs in hardcore
yeah there's still a small team yeah
y'all oh this is this is probably the
worst spot for me to call this missile
but we're gonna do it without a winning
that ours yes I got a headshot on that
guy night I love when you shoot a
friendly it's like a chick your fire
yeah my character your bloody fire oh no
yep I wish you Roberto
I can't can't like it dominating a lot I
still like to play sometimes can be the
way to go if you just wanted like see I
tried to wait I tried to wait me too may
he elevations yeah like I don't
oh he's the second hi yeah the second I
turn he peaked out and I was like oh I
see
if I had just a little bit it's ham over
there it's like my bullets do no damage
over 28 kills as you only got like one
kill streak that entire I don't want to
see this again such BS I died a lot
though oh me too
I've just been on like off today I'm
normally not great but do we want to
catch one more are we good we've
officially reached 12:30 I mean maybe a
2v2 yeah gunfight is real finance it is
we'll do a one gunfight imagine that
yeah thanks for tuning in chat laborious
I was two kills away from getting 30
kills I was close nice but yeah I like
running around a lot we do sometimes it
works well and sometimes it just really
doesn't so true I keep kicking the table
sorry
oh good got take out that aggression
[Laughter]
mean facts are facts homie okay we have
em 13s and shotguns Oh
my grave
thank you gotta both it was sloppy Hey
all that matters that we got the dough
beer yeah Bob Joe I'm scared ding I
wanted the lake run over there
no we got you they did you got this
though it's like the bait is real they
give you a shot II owe you if so you're
like all wanna run over there and use it
oh we like both side in the same spot on
the whole stage I like this gun here's
hoping we do better they know my place
they're probably waiting for me grenades
active you don't have to trust your aim
is better than theirs and go for the
long long range I'll come to you you
just take care of that
look at me like huh well luckily Prozac
you can disable the cross-play if you if
you're worried about that oh yeah
[Music]
maybe we should keep it back yeah this
is why I feel like this mappers wack cuz
like what's the point in not just saying
back in no be really I didn't get my
shot ah that's crazy
no check it out for that camp said I
finally listened to chat and just hang
out I'm gonna die watch there's a
claymore already but I believe in you
I'm scared it's gonna go too overt about
this
you just hope you guess right and go to
the side and he was like not on or
something or when you hold it for too
long and then he's like yeah are we
doing overtime is waiting for it I hate
you I hate you man that's so wax
look at me doing my cool slide too cuz
at least on the other map there's like
not this whole platform back here like
that you kind of like run out yeah
[Music]
hey what I got beautiful know what
Celeste fight or die great attempt
[Music]
that's crazy
it is camping just a hand is now also
finally yeah I don't like these two yeah
it's fine
man they both went up side shoot well
they were both on their stairs like on
each side but you know you know I'm dead
oh wait he kills himself door I gotta go
over that I thought you killed him with
your name I was like oh yeah you can see
their health - at the top oh you got me
- got you flash them
[Music]
we can't in the stream on a whack long
throw that people can view in a bag of
the map the whole game not okay no no we
can't we can't end it like that an
executive decision has been made
yep we're not gonna laying down the
hammer right now one we're gonna fight
and then we're out of here
okay did you play in the Alpha that load
2v2 where you had to pick up your weapon
like on the ground like you started with
this I didn't fun that's like prettier
on site it was only for like one day it
was so fun a lot of people just kept we
had like this unwritten agreement to
just punch each other no one was picking
up guns on the last day he's punching oh
yeah this map I remember this map also
from the Alpha
yeah it's Memphis one all right let's go
Ritchie we got it we got it in this on a
double you going out like no chunks oh
look
oh no they're right the overtime flag
that's all it is ah we got to go for
kills ooh I'm nervous
[Music]
oh yeah one if I didn't get stunned I
might have been able to
[Music]
hmm oh my god you kidding me
I cannot believe that didn't kill us
that shot did not kill her are you
serious are you serious right now I
already knew that start was bad well you
have an assault rifle I do secondary to
hell with this yeah alright now you know
these other guys out there in the back
sniping somewhere don't worry I'm very
scared
should I just creep to the overtime flag
umm just run around in circles and
hopefully he'll miss your shot so you
can see where you mean the sound is a
little deceiving sometimes
even SJ in the chat says you should have
had that one mmm so to that shotgun I
showed up late to the party but I know
this is why I killed him with my
flashbang let's go
I think he's on the right side over here
oh he just threw a flash over here I'm
on the left
I was scared cause he kind of like flash
just frame asks are you guys playing on
PC ruling on ps4 but yeah and we did get
matched up with some other PC players -
[Music]
wow you can't even see my bullets come
on hurting my feelings scope I got hit
three dinosaur alive
nice survivability he's up on top of the
[Music]
onion just
yeah I remember like the deagle being
super powerful and I ate like three
shots just now and survived some guy is
we can't end it like this I refuse we
need a win if we don't win this gunfight
that's it all right
third time's a charm fair enough we have
to go actually do real work but I refuse
to go out like that you know a little
been around before that we did hey
awesome lifestream says music and game
thank you thanks for trying
SJ always always positive in the chat he
says good run good run indie thank you
we try we're trying to do better for you
it was just like you unfortunately for
us we got stuck with to like pistol
rounds for the last two oh yeah alright
maybe I could on my inner camper it was
maybe me too mmm-hmm okay this is a good
start I'm flag to win Lazar says you
need to end it with a dub we have the
real CSS you're catching the tail 2v2
mode the weed says I've been trying for
20 minutes
see I rush last round and they were like
alright let's rush we just gotta set the
tone
oh yeah boys come on come on PQ a little
head out what are those knees left left
left going to our spawn up top seat okay
now then I know we gotta get we gotta
get this table originated okay time to
practice some real patients oh I thought
I oh oh no pressure be careful please
like I heard him next to me about hey I
can watch you in third person this is
cool that's so wack
that's very nice baby
perfect timing we're about to end the
stream oh oh they got me so quickly over
there yeah that is crazy
this is unacceptable what is a new
person forgetting body I know hey I'm
almost on match point
oh yeah ah they're at our spot on the
ramp I didn't see him just using my
blind spot so lucky I miss when we were
doing great earlier
got him nice let's do this let's bring
this back link again let's bring this
back link again yeah no wonder I got him
in the head with the score oh no oh he
got me
there you go there you go yes let's go
okay okay
oh my keep this together Ritchie chat we
could use some motivation Ryan asks he
had some issues to begin with but people
are logging on now
very scared he's here although they're
both on me they're both down below oh my
god
let's go
you got this my heart is going I know
Jackson how's the beta pretty intense at
the moment but it's going good friend I
should download it you got a ps4 all you
got to do is download it you didn't you
don't even have to preorder anymore what
no we tried we did try honestly no but I
will admit last weekend there was some
really crazy like it didn't happen all
the time but like I don't know massive
frame drops or something it was pretty
well alright you guys we tried in like a
whole extra 25 minutes onto the stream
it's all good
tomorrow's community Friday's so Ben and
John we're gonna be joining you guys and
playing some games with you guys so I'm
not exactly sure what they have planned
but if they happen I don't know place
crowd again maybe I'll join up a new
mode will probably yeah just tune in
tomorrow at 11:00 right yes 11:00 a.m.
every weekday you guys that's when we're
here and that's when we play some games
oh man long as like one more you guys
can do it oh I'm so tempted I'm so
tempted
oh you know what we have to not to work
we have to but thank you guys so much
for tuning in and we
we'll catch guys next time